what about the other chris he well  amsword is godly he's a godly man yeah  you when i have worked with him very few  times yeah it's hard not to  arm be inappropriate not like that to me  is handsome yeah but it is kind of wild  is that real it's way bigger than my  head  yes  i also have a little head but it's way  bigger than my head it's a huge jump but  he also is charming  and fun  and kind a kind and a good actor there  are a few of them i mean also you know  sebastian  yes he's kind of like not being hit with  the ugly stick no  um  i don't really want to give mackie too  much air time but he's quite a beautiful  specimen  that's what i mean yes i do not need to  inflate that no anymore maggie feels  three inflated yeah  as well yeah